bixente justin c'est à vous vous êtes
allé et stc ces jeux d'évasion grandeur
nature qui rappelle de concepts
peut-être déjà avec vos bixente mais
puisque la plupart et si peut-être
connaissent déjà savent déjà comment ça
se passe le principe est simple vous
choisissez un scénario à partir de là
vous êtes coincé dans une salle et vous
avez une heure vous en sortir un game
master est présent et vous observent
depuis son ordinateur pour vous donner
des petits indices en cas de besoin la
communication est essentielle si vous
trouvez vous devez tout tenir au courant
l'équipe des avancées de nouveaux
éléments des clés par exemple si vous en
avez et qu'il ya des corps qu'il faut
leur dire bien sûr ce sera ponctuée de
fouilles de réflexion de logique en même
temps mais c'est accessible à tous la
preuve on a réussi vous avez testé
lesquels on a testé du coup deux escape
game avec justin zik site à poissy
engrenage à versailles donc les
scénarios on les a fait à deux mais le
nombre idéal bien sûr pour une équipe
c'est 4 en accord avec tous les games
master bien que les équipes peuvent
aller de trois à six personnes vous avez
un métier difficile d'aller tester sur
vos heures de travail exactement je te
propose peut être qu'on commence par
exit la poisse y aller faut savoir que
c'est un établissement qui tient une
ligne conductrice précise 50% de
réussite sur les salles dixit a ouvert
en 2018 par trois salles à poissy et
depuis trois nouvelles salles ont été
créés à saint germain en laye nous avons
fait la salle prison bêta le pitch il
est lié à l'actualité les prisons sont
surchargées de détenus dont la prison de
poissy je laisse à yoann notre game
masters le soin de vous lire la suite
l'état une petite idée cette idée
sympathique pour réduire le nombre de
prisonniers à petit peine dans les
prisons françaises et ils sont dit
qu'ils allaient mettre un nouveau
concept de prison en place les prisons
bêta
parler ça vous parle pas normal c'est
top secret ouais c'est top secret je
vous révèle une info comme ça ouais je
m'entends bien avec le ministre de la
justice vous révéler l'info en plus la
première est derrière moi ici même à
poissy et c'est après ça que tout
s'emballe et qu'on se retrouve plongé
dans le noir et entre les quatre murs
d'une cellule et bilan malheureusement
on est sorti une est en retard c'est un
échec pour celui c'est exactement ça
c'était donc le premier et on a aussi
testé donc engrenage à versailles
exactement et donc on contre et laurent
andré 7 qui est cogérant il a créé sa
avec son frère ils ont ouvert en 2018
aujourd'hui ils ont quand même cinq
scénarios ils sont basés sur des
histoires vraies certains donc ça met
dans l'ambiance est donc nous on a testé
un autre salle qui était basé sur une
histoire vraie aussi c'est l' affaire
des poisons une affaire d'empoisonnement
qui est survenu à versailles au xviie
siècle et donc louis xiv nous a confié
l'enquète regarder on est quelques
années en arrière en 1679 tout
simplement et donc à cette époque il ya
des empoisonnements à la cour de
versailles donc le roi louis xiv et
affaiblit son pouvoir royal est
affaiblie donc il va demander à louis ii
l'as ready qui est un lieutenant général
de police d'enquêter sur 7 sur cette
affaire donc à ce titre là j'ai reçu une
missive
que vous pouvez lire à toute l'équipe
michel testé les services notre timing
cette fois on a réussi on est sorti au
bout de 56 minutes félicitations à vous
on est plutôt fier 6 minutes 50 minutes
d'avancé sur le timing et pour le coup
j'ai eu l'impression qu'on avait utilisé
moins un disque pour l'autre et skip
james
bond ce qui excite les points forts
c'est le côté immersif et le fait que le
game master et un rôle un peu
particulier on vous en dira pas plus
exactement vous en dit pas plus mais ça
rajoute vraiment beaucoup et c'est ce
que j'ai préféré en fait on s'y attend
pas sinon j'ai beaucoup aimé aussi
d'immersion dans la prison je sais pas
pour toi bixente mais le fait de
commencer on sait lui maintenant ça nous
plombe nasa pour directement dedans et
pour engrenage à versailles je crois que
c'est le petit coup de coeur de justin
je vous laisse le soin d'en dire un peu
plus c'est ça déjà le fait de savoir que
l'histoire a vraiment existé à brimont
lieu ça ça plonge encore une fois dans
l'ambiance mon coup de coeur pour le
coup c'est et les décors chaque nouveau
chaque nouvel élément était complètement
différent on se croyait vraiment à
l'époque à ce moment là en fait on est
en tout cas dans les deux salles il ya
un côté humain en finale parce que c'est
des créneaux de deux heures les masters
s'adapte aux joueurs et prennent le
temps de discuter de débriefer avec
après il ya toujours un petit échange
avant et après puisque vous êtes
amatrice des sketches game pardon le
dernier vous aviez fait dont les
yvelines
je crois qu'il ya un spv au château de
maisons laffitte me semble qu'il ya des
soirées un peu thématique ma chatte mais
le fait oui effectivement et puis on a
eu en plus une salle en plus pendant la
période d'halloween l'occasion de
revenir vous allez fais ce que je veux
dire est ce que vous en pensez
quelques autres noms aussi un glorieux
c'est skype vélizy-villacoublay avec des
scénarios basés sur des films des séries
walking dead l'os ton corps django voilà
merci à tous les deux